so as you can see this guy instagram has
behind cardi B says there's another side
to this story yo think or if the singers
husband off set has been accused of
sliding into another woman's DMS Jade
the girlfriend of rapper Takashi 6-9
posted a video to Instagram that
allegedly shows a message from off set
no no cardi later took to social media
on Tuesday and claimed offsets account
had been hacked adding that she's quote
not entertaining this BS the rapper then
seemingly referenced the couple split in
the past year of needed cheating
allegations yeah I know he doesn't those
come on dink-dink crazy we've been so
good we had we had a sweet weekend a
life has been good that's nice it wasn't
long before Jayde soon responded in her
Instagram story she posted quote the
hack started after you got exposed why
it didn't start at 1:00 a.m. et spoke to
cardi earlier this year about
reconnecting with offset after their
split all right here's what you know the
other day you were walking I can't
remember where you were walking and
someone I asked you if you would offset
of working things out and you said
working working you know yeah
breaking it out yeah yeah we can see the
family back together we were always
gonna be a family death together yeah my
baby loved us both my schedule is so
crazy and it's penny time these are the
times it
you know they recognize the parens they
want to be close to their parents all
the time
[Music]